bonjour dimanche en politique va
commencer dans un instant dans votre
région et puis je vous retrouve à 12h10
avec mon invité olivier faure le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste les
socialistes seront dans les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites le 5 décembre le ps qui joue
son avenir aussi lors des prochaines
élections municipales notamment dans les
grandes villes ses places fortes
traditionnelles la gauche peut-elle se
rassemblent et olivier faur promet aussi
un grand discours sur la laïcité
une question qui a divisé ces dernières
semaines est d'abord notre débat en
région les élus de plusieurs communes
françaises s'inquiètent de la
recrudescence des incivilités et des
violences urbaines comment comprendre et
endiguer ce phénomène dans notre région
on en débat ce matin en direct on se
retrouve dans deux minutes avec les
invités restez avec nous cette semaine
je vous emmène à nevers et ses environs
la loire et l'allier n'a fait une
destination de choix pour les oiseaux
migrateurs
nous les observons depuis 32 ans se
tient à nevers un festival de jazz
impossible pour moi de passer à côté
nous irons y faire un tour et puis vous
me connaissez un faut que ça bouge
alors est-ce qu'elle sportive est ce que
vous connaissez le padel non pas le
paddle le padel c'est un sport de
raquette venus du mexique et bien je
vous montrerai comment ils font et allez
vous rester un c'est aujourd'hui à 12h55
un nouveau c'est là sur france 3
bourgogne franche comté
maintenant
chers français merci d'avoir râler au
sujet des sceaux toute prête
c'était pour saler vous pourrez dîner
avec gears et merci d'avoir aller sur
leur composition e621 légumes grâce à
vous les sous pli et big change et sont
désormais préparés avec 100 %
d'ingrédients naturels
merci d'avoir fait grandir nos soupes
et big
on vous a toujours dit que les légumes
ça fait grandir que ça fait un joli tas
que ça rend aimable
est ce que vous a jamais c'est que celle
aussi des légumes sap le rendre fier
fier parce qu'ils sont issus d'un modèle
coopératif dans lequel chacun a son mot
à dire
alors venez découvrir notre modèle et
participe au choix de la coopérative sur
dossier c'est vous aussi
un chat stériliser peut-être moins
actifs mais grâce à elle qui m'a
stériliser voulait dreer contrôler son
poids son agilité ultima marque experte
en chats stérilisés d'affinités
au moulin de l'été 1
ah oui on a décidé se marier parce
qu'elle attendait un enfant
mais malheureusement ce moment-là plus
beaucoup d'amour torride j'ai compris
qu'il avait fait au mieux qu'ils avaient
pu et à partir de ce moment là je me
suis mise à les aimer
on vient tous de morteau dans le doubs à
côté de la suisse depuis longtemps
depuis toujours en fait c'est important
ça devient en clair sa vie une famille
française lundi à 23h dans votre région
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
chaque jour dans nos communes nous
constatons la dégradation rapide du
vivre ensemble au profit d'une tension
sociale dans un texte adressé au chef de
l'état et au gouvernement publié
dimanche dernier dans le jdd
une cinquantaine de maires appel à
lutter contre les incivilités une
tribune signée par des élus de toutes
sensibilités l'agglomération dijonnaise
mais aussi d'autres communes de notre
région font face depuis plusieurs mois à
des phénomènes de violences urbaines et
des dégradations alors comment endiguer
ces violences et ces incivilités les
communes sont elles laissé seul face à
ces phénomènes comment forces de l'ordre
et habitants agissent et réagissent
le gouvernement va-t-il mettre des
moyens supplémentaires on en débat en
direct ce matin sur france 3 bourgogne
avec nos invités thierry falconnet
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le maire ps de
chenôve en compte dans l'une des
communes concernées par ces violences
vous êtes à l'origine de cette tribune
dont je parlais et vous avez rencontré
christophe castaner et emmanuel macron
cette semaine salut à vous dire bonjour
vous êtes présidente de l'association
défaut média 21 basée à fontaine d'ouche
près de dijon vous porterez ici la voix
des habitants des quartiers tout comme
adel ali race qui président de
l'association soleil d'or à chenôve
merci à tous les deux d'être avec nous
familles d'akata by bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député la république en marche de
côte-d'or vous dirai comment la majorité
et le gouvernement voit ses problèmes et
entend trouver des solutions stéphane
ragonneau bonjour vous êtes le
secrétaire régional du syndicat alliance
police nationale et vous nous direz
comment vos collègues font face quasi
quotidiennement à ses difficultés vous
qui nous regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter cette émission en direct avec
le hashtag dean paul bourgogne sur les
réseaux sociaux alors on va être très
clair et aussi très synthétique
thierry falconnet dans nos communes de
l'agglomération dijonnaise qu'est ce qui
se passe exactement aujourd'hui quand on
parle de violence urbaine d'incivilités
de dégradation c'est quoi le problème
on parle d'équipements publics
vandalisés on parle d'eux
deux véhicules incendiés on parle de
véhicules de police et de
sapeurs-pompiers attaqué par des jets de
protection de projectiles et rend
caillassaient les trams caillassé on
parle aussi de violences verbales et de
violences physiques contre des personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
contre les policiers contre les
émeutiers contre les élus et puis d'un
d'un sentiment que les choses
s'installent et puis que les délinquants
peuvent en toute impunité pratiquer ce
genre ce genre d'agissements certaines
émanent qui existe depuis toujours qui
s'est révélé il ya quelques mois comment
vous diriez les choses alors c'est un
phénomène qui a toujours existé mais
avec une acuité et surtout une durée
jamais connu jusqu alors et ça n'est pas
propre je tiens à le signaler ce n'est
pas propre à la ville de chenôve et non
dans tous les quartiers de la
la métropole dijonnaise mais aussi dans
d'autres villes
je pense qu'en plein à
chanteloup-les-vignes as voilà qui a
fait qui a fait la une de l'actualité il
ya quelques jours ses fans ragonneau les
forces de l'ordre sont confrontées à
quelles difficultés dans ses quartiers
dans ces communes qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que vous vous observez ou une
recrudescence de violence planète alors
que de sources de violence envers nos
collègues envers nos concitoyens
également et puis également une certaine
forme d'impunité
mais vraiment là ça revient reconnaît le
disait la mobilité quoi parce que vous
vous devez bien un moment donné
interpellé des gens
est ce que c'est parce que ce sont par
exemple des personnes mineures on va
être très concret et que donc ils
bénéficient d'une législation qui est
particulière et que ces personnes sont
remises en liberté très rapidement
collectivement oui il ya l'ordonance 45
qui permet comment dire normalement de
traiter judiciairement les mineurs là
actuellement des mineurs de moins de 15
ans sont responsables leur
responsabilité pénale est amoindrie et
donc c'est vous êtes confrontés
essentiellement à des mineurs ou pas
forcément essentiellement à des mineurs
sur certains endroits on s'aperçoit même
si une certaine forme de jeu qui
s'installent ou sein des quartiers jeu à
celui ces voleurs comme on avait
auparavant dans l'agricole dans les
cours d'école mais lorsque l'âge est la
réalité des gens cours de la république
et c'est la vie des habitants
salut abou dia peut-être un mot sur
votre association qui est basée la
fontaine d'ouche avant de
avant de vous entendre sur c'est sur ces
problèmes de de certaines communes de
l'agglomération dijonnaise
notre objectif c'est alors notre
objectif premier c'est vraiment le les
changes le lien social et le vivre sans
le fameux vivre ensemble que tu vas
connaître dit voir disparaître avec ses
amis maires dans une tribune la semaine
dernière c'est vraiment ça comprenant
premier lieu à des la lira ce qui donne
une sensation sur la nuit alors soleil
d'or c'est une association qui a
politique laïque et il est important
pour moi de préciser c'est une
association promouvoir la culture
participe à des actions monétaires et
solidaire et s'impliquer dans la vie
citoyenne
si je suis ici aujourd'hui puis je vous
remercie pour l'invitation ce que je
suis autant que citoyen de 7,7 m
le ville de chenôve attaché un citoyen
français je représente aucune communauté
ni religieuse ni politique
voilà donc je suis un citoyen engagé
dans cette ville de chenôve et j'aurais
souhaité que je serai invité pour vous
parler de la belle vous allez nous
emparer je sais c'est très important
mais mais dites nous comment les
habitants tous les deux ils comment les
âges et je termine suis ce que je suis
vraiment ça me tient vraiment à coeur
j'aurais vraiment parler de cette de
chenôve label chenôve son vignoble son
village ses quartiers populaires et ses
quartiers pavillonnaires parler de cette
ville qui a dix équipes non pour 30000
habitants alors que nous sommes que
14000 donc voilà tout ça ça me tient à
coeur et je leur ai souhaité j'espère
qu'on aura d'autres émissions comme
l'air je le compare déjà bien qu'on est
bien conscient qu'il n'y a pas que des
problèmes dans les communes dont nous
parlons puisqu'il n'ya pas que shawn of
qui est concerné par cette ses
difficultés
dites nous à des délires à skis comment
les habitants de ces communes vivent ces
violences urbaines ces dégradations
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui vous disent je
vous mentirais en vous disant que tout
bien tout va bien madame la marquise
quand il dit c'est une situation qui est
délicate pour les habitants on vit on
est dans la quiétude
je dirais même en aidant la peur parce
que les violences
on sait quand est-ce que ça commence où
ça commence mais on sait jamais quand ça
se termine
et comment ça se termine et ça c'est
cesser problématique pour les habitants
tout le monde pleurait victimes à un
moment donné on a peur parce que
incendié une voiture
on a toujours peur que cet incendie il
peut toucher un immeuble mais aussi que
des habitants qui sont excédés puisse se
forment aux milices sa saison entendus
dans la ville et qui est des morts et
sans nous ces voiles en tant qu il ya
une peur ou qui y est
qui est palpable salière boudiaf c'est
la même question les habitants que vous
représentez aussi à travers vos
associations ils vivent ça comment et
qu'est ce qu'ils en disent finalement et
vivent ça voilà dans la peur forcément
ils ont exposé aussi plein de question
en disant qu est ce qui a fait qu'on en
soit arrivé là aussi ça aussi c'est une
question qu'il faut qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui moi je vais vous la poser
très directement il ya il ya quelques
instants j'entends dire que il s'agit de
mineurs les habitants sont aussi des
parents responsables à un moment donné
je suis tout à fait d'accord on peut
leur dire sans que ce soit un faux pas
c'est notre responsabilité moi je suis
en tant que parent je suis ya aussi donc
moi j'ai mes enfants
voilà je suis à derrière eux à aucun
moment je laisserai un certaine heure de
la nuit elle dort donc on a tous une
certaine forme de responsabilité
maintenant faut que chacun se
l'approprient cette responsabilité que
ce soit les taxes sur les parents on est
tous responsables d'un moment ou un
autre
après il ya des choses aujourd'hui que
l'artiste s'est pas forcément les
problèmes c'est aussi un symptôme faut
savoir que c'est quelque chose qui nous
qui doit nous alerter en lui disant là
quelque chose qui fonctionne pas c'est
quelque chose qui va pas mais ce qu'on
arrive à identifier ce quelque chose
justement on doit tous se poser cette
question la ronde voilà où j'en profite
pour aller il ya des politiques dites
leur qu'il y arrive un moment où moi je
suis sûr qu'on ait loupé un virage
il suffirait qu'on a loupé n'at on pas
vraiment si on reste sur cette voie on
va se crasher comme désillusions passées
au mois ou à droite au mur donc il est
il est important pour les citoyens que
nous sommes que nous mettions tout ça en
question que ce soit le politique tous
ensemble parce que c'est pas puis je
suis désolé de dire à madame de députés
que vous avez appelé la politique de la
russie a annoncé qu'il faut presque un
plan marshall pour tous les problèmes
d'une manière globale ce soit la police
juste première
je suis pas d'accord un problème les
banlieues non c'est tous nos concitoyens
de tout territoire dont les concerne
tout le monde est conscient ça s'arrête
pas à la frontière d'une auto verte on a
fait c'est pas à vous que je vais
apprendre qu'on a on a construit deux
universités à l'extérieur des villes des
usines parce qu'on avait peur de les
problématiques des idées et maintenant
c'est au coeur des devils qu'il faut
qu'il ya il faut qu'ils aient des
solutions je vais être global pas une
solution spécifique pour telle ou telle
ou telle alors fadila khattabi on va
venir dans un instant aux moyens des
forces de l'ordre parce qu'il en faut
certainement mais on voit bien que le
début du problème c'est pas forcément un
problème de manque de forces de l'ordre
on va y venir un premier mais il ya
autre chose il monsieur dit on a raté un
virage
probablement probablement mais ce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est surtout dû à
des politiques qui ont été menées
il y à 40 ans 50 ans je veux dire dans
les années 60 70
on a fait venir une main-d'oeuvre parce
qu'il y avait des sorts iab et du
développement économique etc et on a mis
dans les quartiers qui sont devenus on a
effectivement matière de développement
sur le plan de l'urbanisme fait des
grandes tours et quelque part on a
parqué les gens mais ça on le sait
depuis longtemps
oui mais dans les années soixante
soixante dix on a fait venir
effectivement des populations parce
qu'on était dans les trente glorieuses
premier choc pétrolier dans les années
soixante dix et deuxième choc pétrolier
et dans les années 80 effectivement
chômage de masse des grosses difficultés
c'est aussi une concentration aussi de
la misère dans ces quartiers on est tout
à fait conscient il faut ramener
effectivement du développement
économique de l'emploi de la mort nazis
sociale et de la mixité sociale
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt c'est ce qui se
passe plutôt sur la métropole dijonnaise
est ce que est ce que c'est pas un
chantier qui aurait dû évidemment
essentielle ce moment c'est bien plutôt
et surtout qui paraît comme ça c'est que
le salon la salle mais c'est ce que le
gouvernement le gouvernement est tout à
fait conscient et je voudrais répondre à
monsieur est tout à fait conscient
effectivement qu'il faut agir vite et
fort mais à tous les niveaux au niveau
bien sûr augmenter mais ce n'est pas
qu'une question de moyens au niveau des
forces de l'ordre qui je tiens à rendre
hommage
j'ai passé aussi d'ailleurs une nuit à
patrouiller avec avec didier martin
nuit de vendredi à samedi dans la
métropole pour voir effectivement
quelles étaient les conditions de
travail et ils nous ont interpellés en
disant il faut aussi des moyens mais
aussi à tous les niveaux au niveau de
l'école d'ailleurs je vais interpeller
moi monsieur le maire puisque le
monsieur le maire a bénéficié
dédoublement des classes de cp et de ce1
il faut que l'école de la république
soit avait un véritable ascenseur social
il bénéficie aussi il a répondu à
l'appel à projet du gouvernement les
cités indicative qui demain vont
accompagner les enfants dans les
activités extra scolaires demain aussi
on va déployer sa a été donné en pleine
session budgétaire
les emplois francs et j'espère pouvoir
travailler avec les élus les maires les
forces économiques aussi du territoire
pour les emplois francs le contrat de
génération n'a pas marché et j'espère
que les emplois francs qu'on va déployer
sur tout le territoire
pourquoi s'en charge voilà cinq mille
euros par an sur trois ans pour un cdi
qu'est signé à un jeune ça aussi c'est
très important dans les cités les gens
puissent vivre aussi dans le dans aucune
religion je reprends les habite tout non
il faut aussi un peu dégoûté changer les
choses qu'ils en sortent je pense que
voilà c'est donner une chance
républicaine à tous et à toutes
et permettent à ces jeunes effectivement
de s'en sortir moi quand ils
m'interpellent les jeunes ils demandent
quoi un logement de la formation de
l'emploi
un travail il ya plein de talents dans
ces quartiers qui ne demande qu'à
s'exprimer
alors bien sûr il faut que l'ordre
républicain reviennent il faut et c'est
ce que nous sommes en train de faire
parce que nous payons les conséquences
aussi d'une politique qui a été menée il
y a une dizaine d'années c'est-à-dire
suppression de la police de proximité
suppression des rg la rgpp a fait qu'il
ya une diminution aussi du nombre de
fonctionnaires de police aujourd'hui via
le dispositif et vous m'avez interpellé
et je vous réponds monsieur le maire sur
le dispositif la reconquête des
quartiers reconquête républicaine
aujourd'hui 40 e set territoire en
bénéficient 13 bénéficier en 2000 en
2020 et j'espère effectivement je louve
évidemment l'internaute calme sans
retenue dans le disque connaît
finalement il ya plein de choses qui
sont mises en place mais on ce que je
disais on a l'impression que c'est
tellement colossal comme chantier que ça
paraît difficile à réaliser je veux pas
être pessimiste mais moi je voudrais
revenir sur ce qu'ils aiment surasky
parce que c'est important de le signaler
dans je fais partie d'une association
qui s'appelle villes et banlieues qui
réunit les maires des communes de la
même configuration que que chez nous
nous avons des politiques publiques en
matière d'éducation en matière de sport
en matière de culture en matière de
développement durable qui sont
exemplaires
voilà les les collectivités d'ailleurs
avec avec l'aide de l'état font font
leur travail
le renouvellement urbain des millions
d'euros d'ailleurs sa neuvième ça nous a
été reproché des millions d'euros ont
été investis pour georges et et et dans
l'avenir
encore encore des millions de ses
passifs il jouait simplement simplement
dire que aujourd'hui et c'est le sens de
l'appel des maires aujourd'hui toutes
ces politiques publiques qui n'ont pas
marché ne non c'est pas ça c'est que
toutes ces politiques publiques ne
peuvent être menée que si la condition
du maintien de la de la tranquillité
publique et de la sécurité des habitants
peut être assurée or pour le volet
tranquillité les maires font leur
travail
je crois savoir qui est un projet un
projet ça nous a été dit au congrès des
maires à projets pour donner encore plus
de pouvoirs au maire sur sur ces
questions mais est-ce que ça va pas se
traduire par un transfert de charges
nouveau est-ce qu'on va pas nous
demander à nous les maires alors que
nous n'en avons pas les compétences de
faire de la sécurité publique mais de
l'ordre public
moi je suis très inquiet sur sur cette
évolution parce que qui dit transfert de
charge 10 transferts de compétences mais
aussi transfert de dépenses abdelali
race qui est salie à boudiaf sur ce que
dit thierry falconnet est ce que vient
de dire aussi la députée fadila khattabi
part qu'on commence il faut d'abord
rétablir l'ordre vous êtes d'accord avec
ça bien entendu notant que vous savez
quand on est en paix quand on peut nous
donnons tranquillité on peut on peut
faire des choses
effectivement si on est si on est si on
a la peur c'est on a peur de faire des
choses bien entendu et derrière votre
première priorité une fois qu on
rétablit l'ordre qu'est ce que c'est
vous savez moi ce que j'ai dit je
reviens ce que j'ai dit au début c'est
pas c'est pas la politique de russie et
c'est pas la politique de l'urgence
parce qu'à force de travail que tu
hurles heures
en oublie l'essentiel mois pour moi et
je reste là dessus il faut qu'il y ait
un plan global tout ça soit l'éducation
alain pouget ce que nous faisons pas
voilà tous les niveaux le dédoublement
des classes je veux dire que personne
quand ça a été mis en place et j'étais
avec monsieur le maire plus que j'ai
assuré la rentrée 2010 8 avec vous j'ai
pu échanger à la fois avec l'équipe
pédagogique et les parents d'élèves et
tout le monde nous disait vous allez
vous casser la figure vous n'allez pas
pouvoir le faire on l'a fait et
aujourd'hui ça donne de très bons
résultats avec le chausseur bien sûr
mais c'est une justement sur le rôle de
l'éducation l'assuré à bordeaux
aujourd'hui on l'a vu ce qui s'est passé
dernièrement on voudrait interdire
l'accès des mamans à l'école les gens
commencent par sa déjà on crédite la
distance
bref l'état actuel fait que ben on veut
interdire l'accès aux parents d'élèves
au sein même de l'école normale
alors je crois que le travail je maurice
déjà par l'art déjà on doit laisser les
uns tout effarant s'intéresser
s'investir pour que madame que les
lèvres je me permets se sentent se
sentent voilà rassurés 60 les parents se
sentent investis au 6 juin sujet d'une
part et à partir de là effectivement en
tant que parent on est tous responsables
de nos enfants jusqu'à leur majorité
voire temps qu'ils vivront sous notre
toit solaire sur l'école non tout à fait
je partage de toute façon votre point de
vue il ya eu un amendement des
républicains dans le cadre de l'école
pour la confiance de la confiance et qui
a été rejetée par notre groupe je me
suis déjà exprimé là dessus il n'est pas
question d'exclure effectivement les
mamans qui pour les enfants d'ailleurs
c'est important et qui participe et
contribue effectivement à la scolarité
des enfants et puis aux activités
également la périscolaire troyen moi je
suis atterrée par ce débat est ce que
c'est vraiment est ce que la france a
besoin de ce débat non des jeux et même
coup les journalistes d'ailleurs parce
que vous avez y en a qui sont fait leurs
choux gras de ce phénomène
alors si c'est quelque chose de deux
minimes
faites dans les médias d'autres
problèmes des autres je t'appelle tu
d'accord qu'elle soit un peu parlé de ça
et puis même le monde aux plaisirs
démodés d'aidé à des moyens colossaux je
vais dire au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale tout ça pour un film phénomène
moi s'amuse saleban droite citoyens je
tiens à dire ça n'est même pas du tout
du gros alaric mais quand on m'a proposé
sur nous voilà c'est suffisant dit
aujourd'hui ben agissent malheureusement
comme ça il faut chercher plus loin
savoir où elle va l'être oui c'est sa
force et vous avez il ya une certaine
forme de discrimination ces jeunes
subissent énormément de discrimination
face alors à l'emploi enfin sur logement
fha ce travail fin face à leur vie du
quotidien et d'huile mes coups j'ai
l'avant en france il ya des tas de gens
qui ont des nations et si on n'est pas
je veux trouver du travail il faut pas
nous ils vont pas pour autant qu'elle
ait cédé du terrain victimiser oui parce
que ses moyens on rentre dans un
engrenage complet chez lui et je
conseille même les plus profonds il va
falloir qu'on va venir sur la sécurité
voir comment on rétablit leur jeu je
pense aussi que et je pense que monsieur
ragonneau on dirait on dire un mot nos
quartiers sont aussi miné par le trafic
de stupéfiants et par les revenus que
génère le trafic de stupéfiants économie
parallèle économie parallèle qui s'est
installée dans le quartier et qui minent
le pacte républicain
comment expliquer un jeune qui touche
entre 50 et 100 euros pour faire du gué
en bas d'une tour par jour vous êtes le
calcul ce que ça peut rapporter par mois
comment expliquer à un jeune qu'il faut
qu'ils fassent des études qu'il faut
qu'ils travaillent qu'ils fassent des
efforts pour obtenir le smic peut-être
le smic
un jour ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
quelque chose qui est au coeur de ces
problématiques et moi ce que je voudrais
à travers à travers notre action commune
les habitants les parlementaires le
gouvernement sait que nous rétablissions
une forme d'exemplarité républicaine
c'est à dire que les jeunes de nos
quartiers qui effectivement peuvent
avoir le sentiment
d'être discriminés sur le plan
territorial sur le plan de leur leur
origine sur le plan de leurs origines
sociales et bien que ces jeunes
reprennent confiance dans la république
et dans le modèle républicain qui est
celui de faire des études de réussir à
l'école d'avoir un emploi d'avoir une
famine elle s'installe à tous un très
mal de vivre de vivre normalement
stéphane ragonneau le trafic de
stupéfiants pour vous c'est un problème
oui alors moi je voudrais dire que moi
je suis un enfant de ces quartiers et
moi jusque dans les années 80 j'ai vécu
heureux on était heureux pourquoi parce
qu'il y avait un service public
et aujourd'hui c'est ça il n'y a plus de
service public en termes d'éducation
carte de police avait auparavant il y
avait d'un des petits postes de position
qui ont tous disparu que syndicats quand
elle disait on a supprimé la police de
proximité est avancé c'est un tort avant
de supprimer oui c'est à tort dans le
sens parce qu'il ya plus de policiers il
y avait une présence
il y avait une présence accrue à chenôve
constamment à chenôve à la fontaine
d'ouche à talant à fontaine-lès-dijon
tous a disparu pourquoi parce qu'on a
enlevé les policiers ont été enlevés du
terrain et aujourd'hui ne font que
l'urgence est là je vous rejoins quand
on fait que d'urgence bout d'un moment
ça ne colle plus et nous ça se traduit
la souffrance au travail fait
on a en haut et bien sûr on a enlevé les
policiers mais on a enlevé ni d'autres
services publics vous ressentez comme ça
ben oui forcément les gens sont un peu
plus livrés à eux même ne serait-ce que
pour un papier administratif on leur dit
d'aller sur internet
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire ya plus
de relations et de relations humaines on
a tous des humains déshumanisé on attend
les gens ne sont plus ne sont plus
écoutés en fait ils sont face à une
machine qu'est ce que vous voulez que
l'on crée du lien bras traversa la seule
présence publique souvent la seule
présence publique ces américains qui
c'est ce sentiment est dans l'urgence ce
seront les policiers et les pompiers
tout à fait oui ils sont en première
ligne et qui d'ailleurs sont pris à
partie effectivement stéphane ragonneau
comment on fait alors oui j'ai bien
compris que la question du trafic de
stupéfiants presse c'est un peu sournois
et puis c'est difficile à évaluer a
évalué oui et puis il ya donc ces
violences aujourd'hui vous êtes
confrontés à quelles difficultés et vous
avez besoin de quoi pour résoudre ces
problématiques
bon on l'a dit en fait on a besoin de
policiers on a besoin de police et pour
pouvoir intervenir en urgence mais aussi
au quotidien et au quotidien voilà est
présent au quotidien
ça permettrait déjà nos collègues
spécialisés part donc pour le trafic de
stups à travailler sereinement pour les
renseignements nouveaux renseignements
territoriale également et puis aussi
avoir un lien avec la population
aujourd'hui on vient on prend des
cailloux on répond on essaye interpellé
est on obligé de repartir
elle est où les discussions avec la
population n'existe plus aujourd'hui
alors fadila khattabi vous avez
rencontré le cabinet de christophe
castaner avec votre collègue didier
martin j'imagine que comme l'a fait à
plusieurs reprises tiré falconnet ou
encore françois rebsamen
vous avez demandé des moyens
supplémentaires alors concrètement et
s'en allait il nous reste 5 minutes
d'émission vous le dis comme ça
est-ce qu'on vous a promis des choses
alors on peut dire qu'on se réjouit
d'ailleurs que le calme revienne d'une
certaine façon là il en train de revenir
un peu fragile wallace mais
effectivement c'est tragique mais je
peux pas dire que le gouvernement ne
fait rien dans la mesure où il est en
train d'augmenter le nombre de
fonctionnaires de police actuellement
sauf que et monsieur le maire le sait
très bien
il faut du temps c'est à dire il fallait
les recruter vous informer avant qu'ils
ne soient opérationnels à ce jour dès
que ces jeunes fonctionnaires sont
sortis de l'école on pare au plus urgent
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui dans le
cadre du dispositif quartier reconquête
républicaine 47 villes ont bénéficié du
dispositif
c'est à dire que on augmente les
effectifs de ces quartiers qu'est ce que
vous aimez le cabinet de cristal quatre
genres et dylan
à deux difficultés en cas d'urgence
effectivement nous a promis d'envoyer
des effectifs supplémentaires
immédiatement dès qu'on les alertent
immédiatement et ils vont tout faire
pour essayer de faire en sorte que
chenôve enfin la métropole depuis ce
bénéficier de ce fabrice abriel
vous avez aussi rencontré christophe
castaner vous avez failli croisé le
président a recueilli que vous étiez
avec lui à l'elysée et de nombreux
maires lors du congrès des maires
est-ce que christophe castaner vous dis
la même chose
ou est-ce qu'il ya deux discours selon
qu'on est député la république en marche
et les maires de communes concernant ce
parfum je voulais ce je vous laisse
cette appréciation
christophe christophe castaner a été un
peu agacé par le fait que je lui remette
l'appel des maires et il m'a dit qu'il
ya des prêts faits pour ça donc je
trouve que là aussi pour un maire qui
subit une population qui subissent
depuis six mois c'est cesser ces actes
de violence qui a alerté on peut pas me
reprocher de ne pas avoir alerté il
préfet et le directeur départemental de
la sécurité publique
elle procure la public j'ai fait tout ce
qui était en mon pouvoir en tant que
maire avec mes compétences pour endiguer
ce phénomène
quand on voit un tel mépris moi je le
dis je le dis à telle mépris j'ai
vraiment été renvoyée au préfet donc je
rencontrerai à nouveau monsieur le
préfet et je ferai le point avec toutes
les demandes que j'ai fait
tu rr quartier de reconquête
républicaine bien si les moyens de
sécurisation qui n'existe plus et ça
n'est pas propre à dijon ça n'est pas
propre nationale la côte d'or ces
nationale il n'ya plus les préfets n'ont
plus à leur disposition de forces de
sécurité qui peut mobiliser
j'ai rencontré également mais ce
castaner on a parlé avec le préfet de
l'yonne le préfet du jura et on leur
promet on leur promet ni rien donc alors
ça va venir ça va venir moi je vraiment
il ya de gros efforts qui sont faits le
gouvernement est vraiment conscient
gradient enregistrés et fort vite et
fort
et puis ne dit pas qu'il a été agacé
enfin avant de l'interpeller vous faites
un courrier vous parlez d'un curry du
gouvernement que fait que font
maintenant qu'il allait à l'estanque il
il travaille au quotidien avec les
habitants en avion démission mais
établissement si vous deviez c'est après
notamment une phrase qui est terrible il
m'a dit cela devient non assistance à
personne en danger
ces points cette fois ça y est vous dire
si vous aviez christophe castaner ou
emmanuel macron face de vous lui
demanderiez koala en deux mots d'agir
rapidement et nous donner les moyens
nécessaires à nos villes nos communes
pour être en paix vous êtes en phase
avec les dépouilles donc est-ce que tu
as les falconets on peut dire que
finalement gérard collomb quand il a
quitté le ministère de l'intérieur avait
raison quand il disait on vit
côte-à-côte attention qu'on ne vive pas
face à face tout à fait mais moi je veux
terminer par une note positive
oui tu as loupé avec ce nouveau label
schoofs est la ville la plus sportive de
bourgogne franche comté cette aire de
jeux 2024 pour les jeux olympiques c'est
la ville du revenu minimum étudiant
hier nous avons planté la première forêt
comestibles de l'agglomération
dijonnaise price et la cité éducative
c'est une politique racialiste dynamique
pour les jeunes pour les aînés je les
rejoins tout à l'heure pour un repas les
personnes âgées de chez nous c'est sage
autres communautés sincère et d'autres
communes de la région dont on parle et
vous avez raison de le dire et
d'ailleurs sur notre antenne dans nos
journaux on ne parle pas que de ce qui
va pas on parle aussi de ce qui va bien
merci mesdames messieurs d'avoir accepté
de débattre en direct ce matin sur un
sujet difficile et délicat merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis aujourd'hui dans un
instant un point sur l'actualité
régionale ça sera en compagnie de maeva
damois de la partie nationale de
dimanche en politique francis letellier
reçoit olivier faure le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
bon dimanche à tous sur france 3